einen wunderschönen guten Tag auf
vielfachen Wunsch des ein oder anderen
klicksum Zuschauers gibt es heute ein
Making Of wir fahren es ist
9:41
uh Richtung Süddeutschland um Samy
Slimani zu besuchen Herr Tutorial bei
Youtube der erfolgreichste Guru
überhaupt am Steuer sitzt Ivo von
Brentano kampferprobter Kameramann hier
so sieht aus genau kampferprobter
Kameramann hier bei klickom und Florian
Burda er ist der Assistent zum ersten
Mal übrigens dabei aber manche werden
ihn vielleicht kennen er hat eine der
nein die erfolgreichste nutzerfrage
überhaupt gestellt an Bushido und zwar
ging es darum welche Musik man am besten
bei World of Warcraft hört und außerdem
ist er eben World of Warcraft Experte
und hat vor diesem Interview mit Bushido
eine kleine Schulung mit mir gemacht
also von daher auch eng mit klicksum
verbunden ja und wir fahren jetzt und
fahren so jetzt habe ich mal die Kamera
in die Hand genommen auch mal alles zu
dokumentieren ich fahre hier ein
wunderschönen
Tag und die anderen was machen sie
Schlaf genauso wie der her da hinten der
schläft auch
das ein fahtier nur ich muss hier wieder
fahren alleine muss mich jetzt hier
alleine
beschäftigen ich lös dich ja nachher ab
also wir sind hier im Starbucks in
Esslingen und Sam ist schon da hallo uns
gerade erste mal die Hand gegeben machen
wir noch mal für die Kamera so jetzt
haben wir das Problem es ist ein
bisschen eng und laut wir müssen mal
gucken wo wir am besten
hingehen ganz ehrlich hier ist hier ist
definitiv zu laut hier ist es zu laut
meinster man kann es hier nicht machen
ja es ist zu laut und es ist in der
Stunde auch nicht weniger los hier ja
glaub ich
auchauen gar nicht ja es ist auch zu eng
es ist auch es ist zu eng es ist zu voll
es ist zu laut das passiert uns ab und
zu mal aber wir haben bisher immer eine
Lösung gefindenfunden und die suchen wir
jetzt mal
ja so das ist also das Pflaster von
Esslingen wir laufen jetzt hier durch
die wunderschöne Altstadt und
suchenff ein Kaffee guck
betriebsam ist wie gerade im Starbucks
das geht nicht
schönön klavierladen ja klavierladen ist
schlecht glaube ich deswegen Kaffee ist
besser aber oh das sieht nicht gut aus
das ist auch
proppenvoll guck mal hier gibt's eine
Wedding
boutike schick aber jetzt da darf nachh
ein Kleid aussuchenr
danke so also unsere Körpertemperatur
ist um ca 5° gesunken wir kennen jetzt
alle kneipenraurants und caffés hier in
Esslingen und ich muss ehrlich sagen zum
ersten Mal sieht es schlecht schlecht
aus oh Gott das ist auch die Kälte man
kann seinen Mund kaum noch bewegen ja
rangaogischw haben wir ja mal draußen im
Freien Interview ich finde aber bei
diesen Temperaturen kommt das nicht in
Frage oder was sagst du Ivo ja oder wir
besorgen uns keine glühwe dann könnte
man darüber reden aber dann wird das was
ganz anderes ganz anderes interiew
Lichtstimmung ist super ja super
Lichtstimmung ja wir sind wieder
unterwegs in Essling war leider tote
Hose also nichts zu finden wo wir hätten
drehen können wir sind jetzt auf dem Weg
nach Stuttgart und ja suchen da jetzt
einen Drehort das ist unsere Rettung
Brez hier beim Brez Shop in Stuttgart
gibt es nicht nur fantastische Sofas
sondern wir bekommen hier auch eine
perfekte interviewecke Ivo richtet sie
gerade schon ein du bist zufrieden ja
hier was raus machen super ja da geht's
dann gleich los wir holen jetzt das
Equipment und dann sind wir
dran auf das
Stativ ja jetzt muss erstmal der ganze
Klumpatsch aus dem Wagen geräumt werden
man muss sich immer irende welgelchen
besorgen haben wir jetzt und da kommt
das alles
rein so jetzt wird hier
aufgebaut packt seinen Werkzeugkoffer an
den Mann weil da wird immer geucht die
erste Lampe steht schon aber da kommen
noch einige
dazu unser prominenter Gast steht schon
bereit mit einer
Freundin normalerweise ist es ja so den
Gast den sehe ich ja erst wenn das
Interview beginnt jetzt müssen wir
wieder eine Sonderregelung aktivieren
hallo Samy noch mal so geht das so ja
folgendes wir dürfen jetzt nicht
miteinander reden okay weil sonst
quatschen wir uns leer auf wenn wir über
andere Themen reden das heißt du musst
dich in die eine Ecke setzen
hier und ich muss mich in die andere
Ecke setzen danach nach dem Interview
können wir quatschen bis Fransen
bekommen aber jetzt vorher ist blöd okay
gut dann das ist ganz wichtig beim
Interview okay wusste ich noch nicht
also bis gleich bis ja so sieht unser
Set dann aus Lampe Lampe
Lampe Lampe also Lampen bis zum
abwcken ja es kommt vor selten kommt es
vor manchmal ist es so heiß da kann man
gar nichts tun da läuft einfach die
bröhe runter hier ist es ein bisschen
warm und da hilft ein alter
moderatorentrick Schmerzgel
auf habe ich vom bbel Schäfer
Schmerzgel in den
Nacken so das kühlt da hinten und dann
wird man insgesamt kühl und mit dem
Schwitzen ist es vorbei so jetzt muss
ich sein persönlicher Geheimtipp mein
persönlicher Geheimtipp geliieen von
berbelchäfer ist wirklich eine Ausnahme
meistens geht
es ich find auch überhaupt nicht so
schlimm die Brille ab kurz ma ich mal
der Nasenrücken der glänzt besonders
gerne das ist übrigens auch typisch für
ein Dreh es ist eigentlich alles
aufgebaut aber dann stellt der
Kameramann fest es fehlt noch eine Lampe
wir müssen dringend noch den Hintergrund
da hat er mich festgestellt verdammt das
ist hier so düster hinter Christop das
muss einfach besser aussehen und Ivo ist
ein Perfektionist deswegen kommt da
jetzt noch diese 800 Watt Lampe hin
damit es da hinten ein wenig heller wird
ja das sieht doch schon ganz anders aus
dank dieser
Lampe so jetzt gibt es also die
Begrüßung das wichtigste ist dabei wir
haben uns vorher nicht unterhalten wir
haben zwar ganz kurz gesehen haben wir
auch mitgedreht aber jetzt kommt die
wirklich erste Begrüßung dann geht's zum
Platz und dann machen wir das Interview
mal gucken wie es geht ich gebe ihm
jetzt
Handzeichen jetzt ist blöd knöpft sich
gerade den Schuh zu jetzt kann er kommen
super so hallo Samy das freut mich Dich
persönlich jetzt endlich mal in 3D hier
zu begrüßen freut mich ebenfalls in
Stuttgart du bist gespannt ja ein
bisschen aufgeregt aber das legt sich
glaube ich das gehört dazu bin ich auch
so wir haben da drüben die Ecke
eingerichtet schon gesehen bitte und
zwar der linke Sessel mit armben ganz
kin
so sehr schön jetzt machen wir gut
richtig nett
hier